[Music]
bart and joe
you guys you look at me and said bar and
you say look at him and say joe
in my head i had already said bart by
the time i looked this way i suppose you
guys don't have like a
name together like bow
jar
like a shark but it's in your jeans
yeah we would look like a jerk
charts coming over i'm doing that that's
it yeah that's all right yeah someone
photoshop our faces together
as a jar baby like those things like if
couple of what your baby would look like
you guys should do that
and it'll be oh my god it's gonna be an
ugly baby
especially right now a very hairy baby a
hairy baby a hairy buff
baby thickest neck ever
taiko with a beard yeah basically all
right chart what's up
okay sorry so you guys have um expressed
how you're just like so excited you'd be
down to go to vegas
well what if i told you that there's
this brand new
hotel like this resorting casino that is
only
for 21 and over oh wait what adults only
is that all the hotels no no i mean like
circus circus kids
but like all hotels like they can't
bring their kids there oh yeah
they have family they can't bring their
kids yeah this one's no families get the
[ __ ] out
kids i don't have anything against
families though well a lot of people do
they do yeah once you have the family
you're like i don't have anything wrong
this would be good for singles or this
would be your parents trying to get away
from kids
yeah it makes sense because like think
about like some weddings before like hey
can you not bring your kids
which is chill and they have cruises
like that yeah i understand yeah good
freak
those are called sex cruises really will
you just hook up
love hugs i've always heard of those
boats like love both are they real
i thought it was a hookup singles
cruises yeah oh
that's weird is it i wouldn't want to i
don't know
like you're in the middle of the ocean
but everyone's still thirsty yeah
i think it makes sense well i'm
imagining a boat full of good looking
people though
like i don't imagine never good looking
yeah i don't imagine like walmart people
when it usually that's what happens it's
kind of like everyone goes oh it's a
nudist beach and you think all these hot
girls and you go and it's all these
grandpas and grandmas and [ __ ] that's
real life
yeah and there's like some weird yoga
guy and it's like [ __ ]
that's not what i wanted
it's always a yoga guys man she's gonna
spread your butthole in front of you
weird ass i've always wanted to go to a
nude beach i've never i want to go too
i do too i'll be the weird yoga guy i
always always wonder like if i go to a
nudist beach would i just
and like inherently just get a boner
like i don't know just look at the
grandpa
how do you how do they keep it down i
don't think because they're not
sexualizing you
they're super models everywhere yeah but
probably being sexualized it's supposed
to be about like freedom it's not about
like oh let me get
get a glimpse at your titties true but
like if i was there with you though you
know i mean like
i'd be like well my wife is pretty
[ __ ] hot you see me naked all the
time like you don't have but now it's in
public food but not on the beach though
coming on the beach yeah
it's kind of little king's [ __ ] dope
true i wonder like do they have like a
no
phone policy like what if you take
pictures of people naked that's weird
that's like an invasion i think like the
whole nudist community
from what i've read and stuff like
they're very like
open and accepting and very like nude
and um yeah so they'd just be really
like
shame it would be nice to if i could
just walk out naked
from time to time i love that like i
don't know why it's so
dangerous when we went to croatia we
went to this one of the beaches
and there was a girl there topless and i
was like oh my god i could totally take
my top off and no one gives a [ __ ] and
you did it
i didn't do it why are the beaches there
so blue
because it's uh well the one that we
were at is the adriatic sea
so it's like a smaller my friend's there
right now he's like oh it's so blue
it's so so blue he took pictures i'm
like this looks like a magazine
yeah because they're allowing um they're
allowing travel
from certain countries and and he's he's
in czech republic
travel bubble because they're like this
country you guys were responsible so you
could come here
this country you could come here say not
america too we can't go anywhere
from like europe right now yeah yeah
we're like the weird greasy
kid that eats his boogers nobody wants
to hang out with him right now well that
was europe at first and we're like
don't come over here italians and then
now they're just like
don't come over here no they're like
don't come over don't come over here
no no no this is why they hate america
yeah that's true i'm so sorry i'm sorry
i understand now yeah they understand so
what is this hotel like yeah anyway so
this one's called
circa las vegas and it's a
44 story resort it has 777
rooms it's a big one lucky
it will be open in they're saying in the
article in december but then
like on the twitter it's saying excuse
me october so i'm not sure
but so probably next year yeah we got so
many delays and [ __ ]
yeah yeah so this is what it looks like
in this little this will be in downtown
vegas
is that the old d remember that [ __ ]
the d
in downtown vegas the d oh they might be
remodeling a whole
okay so this is old vegas like all the
other yeah like on fremont street
oh okay fremont i think that's an old
hotel that they were modeling
well they did say that this is oh no no
no uh
from what i read was that for the first
time since 1980
this is the first ground-up resort
development in downtown you have to
really
hate seeing children right to go there
because in like most of vegas is already
like you know 2001 and up
style but like you just hate the fact
that you might glance at a child
so then you go here or if your room your
room is next
yeah if your room is next to a room with
the family sometimes they're just
screaming and [ __ ] inside
you're running down the hallway or
you're trying to have like loud sex and
then but then you hear
kids in the next room over you're kind
of like what's the weird combination of
things that's happening right now that's
true so having like just a hotel full of
adults it's kind of like i can be a
[ __ ] like you know
[ __ ] and not feel bad at all ever
but imagine getting a room there now
like you're just surrounded by moaning
noises over here
over there everyone's freaking out
having a rager and you're like [ __ ] this
is a bad hotel idea
where is it unless that's what you want
yeah you just probably like chill out
there
like i just don't like kids but i didn't
want all this moaning
that's true they should have stayed at a
senior hotel then
or no no wait kids not moaning kids
screaming
or people having sex with moaning you
have to choose between the two i guess
i've
been in a hotel before where the room
next to me was just having really loud
sex
it was so entertaining the whole time
yeah it's not going to last very long
you're even going to turn on the tv or
anything you're just like wow
oh they changed positions they're happy
for them i'm happy for them it's good
for you
me christina and ant we stayed at a
place together
in um hawaii and this was on maui
and then the room next to us we heard a
moaning we're like in the morning like
oh [ __ ] i think they're doing it
and we're just giggling right and then
we go to breakfast oh was that when we
were there
i remember you telling us a story too
you're like dude there's still
it was like a meth field like jeez and
it wasn't just like
like romantic like long hour sex it was
oh [ __ ]
dude and then the way that the bathroom
was too it was like a vent that
connected to theirs and we were just
like
me and i were like trying to listen to
the event like damn that's crazy
i remember when i was little i woke up
in my house my family's house and all
here is
oh like an owl and i was like oh what
the [ __ ] and i was like god it's going
on forever it was a pigeon outside
i thought it was one of your aunties or
something like damn [ __ ] traumatized
i realized oh it's
a [ __ ] pigeon so we're good rather be
a pigeon than auntie
no i'd be down to go to this hotel
though because
it is just nice being okay so you know
over the years how vegas tried to
rebrand to be more family friendly so
there's way more families there
why well it happened in the 90s because
so previous to the 80s right
vegas was mob run ran so it was mo it
was
real adult disneyland like you go there
you could
[ __ ] gamble and be an adult and
there's no kids running around
and then in the 90s the corporations
took over
more money the corporations came in they
were like well
doesn't it make more sense to get people
to make it family friendly so everyone
will come and then dad could gamble or
like mom can gamble and then there's
like
things like circus circus and that's why
circus circus was so [ __ ] popular
because a lot of just people came in
droves and then families
and so that brought way more money into
vegas that makes sense family friendly
usually does make more money
like in the gaming world nintendo is
actually the highest selling
uh console because there's more like
family games that people can play
together their kids and stuff
yeah and there's just more money to be
made because like they need to
find ways to like you know entertain the
kids while
you know they're spending money in the
casino so they got rid of the
the nude girl cards too oh
part of my childhood me too i'm picking
up movies
she's looking down like oh
yeah that sound yeah
yeah there's always some mexicans with
their neon t-shirts
true oh we got i mean
yeah they're no longer around wow but i
want to see what
old vegas is like before when
you know i started going as a kid like
because then it was like
i see all these movies and i see all
these like how
it was just this kind of like classy but
then
kind of dangerous and then everyone's in
like suits and [ __ ]
you know what scene always pops up in my
head when i think of vegas in the 70s
it's always
uh the ocean's 11 movie the scene where
there's a guy
who just takes a whole bunch of money
from the the table and just
books it outside and he gets shot in the
front
i imagine casino that movie with uh
robert de niro yeah de niro and i
imagine rush hour
russia rush hour that's the 90s
that's what just when i think of like
vegas and like the ideal thing
dude life back then like in the 80s or
70s during like the cocaine era
was probably so fun if you're white if
you're white yeah that's true
so [ __ ] fun dude in miami yeah if
you're white
everything else it would suck for you
you probably got a hell of [ __ ] hair
stuck in your mouth
that's true that is true [ __ ] that's
right a lot of shaggy carpets everywhere
yeah they did not know how to decorate
what a cigarette smells i could smell it
right now it might
be like yeah just smoke every old wood
do you guys remember when airplanes used
to have that cigarette ashtray in the
middle
yeah remember that yeah is that weird
yeah oh yeah we are [ __ ]
sick there was a dude the airplane had a
smoking section in a non-smoking section
even hotels too yeah i was like 14
and we snuck some cigarettes on the
plane and we were going to japan
and we were like we thought we were so
cool smoking in our chairs
what yeah where were your parents they
weren't with us
you were flying alone no we were with
the church group
perfect that's crazy
they didn't say anything we weren't in
our area i want to be like i want to be
in the 80s if i was in the 80s i want to
be a
white man working in uh what is it wall
street
doing a [ __ ] ton of coke so like wolf of
wall street yeah
that sounds fun [ __ ] yeah that sounds
fun if you're white i want to throw a
lobster at a fbi agent
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you